I already know that what food allergies I have, and I am mostly gluten, dairy, and sugar-free
already. What type of diet do you recommend that a phase 2 or phase 3 lime person follow?
So phase 2 lime is what I have termed people that have chronic lime where
the bacteria has not gone. The bacteria has gone intracellular, but you haven't formed any
self-antibody. So you're not in an autoimmune phase. Phase 3 lime is my term for someone who is
now formed self-antibody because of their lime infection. Now there's other reasons why you can
develop an autoimmune disease not just because of a bacterial infection,
Borrelia, or something. There's lots of different things that can trigger an autoimmune
disease. That means that your system created self-antibodies. But what you have to look for
with lime disease or if you do have self-antibodies, you have to look for what are my triggers.
So triggers can change over time. So let's say dietary triggers are one thing and they're
a very common thing. Maybe the most common thing. But if I'm already dairy-free, I'm already gluten-free
and I'm already sugar-free, what else do I need to look for? Well, it still can be valuable to run
a CyRex 10 profile because you may have developed antibodies to things that are in gluten-free foods
and you don't know it. You might not be noticing any inflammation in the gut. Therefore, you don't
think that food is causing any issues, but it can be still causing inflammation in the gut,
not causing symptoms there, but causing symptoms in the brain. Therefore, giving you symptoms with a lot
what would be known as a lime flare. So if you think you're in phase 2 or phase 3 lime and you're not
having any problems, your life is going well and you're not experiencing a great deal of symptoms
or anything. Maybe there isn't anything you need to do. But if you are noticing flares, you're
noticing symptoms, you need to dig a little bit deeper and see if food is, you've got to look for
what are called triggers. So anything can be a trigger that is setting off an immune response that's
setting off a flare. So that can be a food that isn't necessarily causing you any tummy issues. So
I don't have any issues when I eat corn. So I know it's not it. Well, that's not necessarily true. You
might not have any stomach issues when you eat corn, but it's causing inflammation in your brain and
that's causing your lime flare. So it's still valuable if you're having these flares, if you're having
symptom patterns to do a food sensitivity panel. There's other things that cause flares too. So if
you're on the autoimmune course, you'll see that there are tons of different things can cause flares,
not just dietary things. So looking for things that are what are termed triggers that can be
triggering an immune response and triggering a worsening of your condition is what you really want
to dig into and look for.